soit on a frôlé la catastrophe
aujourd'hui à 4 canaveral en floride la
navette discovery s'apprêtait à décoller
les moteurs étaient déjà allumé il ne
restait plus que quatre secondes avant
que théoriquement elle s'envole
c'est un moteur semble-t-il qui a lâché
le décompte a été immédiatement
interrompu tandis que les services de
sécurité devait enrayer un début
d'incendié
jacques violet on a effectivement passé
à côté du drame
quatre secondes après la mise à feu des
moteurs et seulement quatre secondes
avant le décollage
l'ordinateur de bord arrête tout un des
trois moteurs principaux ne s'est pas à
lui mais il faut stopper la combustion
des deux autres et surtout éteindre un
début d'incendié d'hydrogène liquide des
jets d'eau sont immédiatement déclenché
jaillissent des tuyères dans ce gros
réservoir rouge derrière la navette
il y à quelques deux millions de litres
d'oxygène et d'hydrogène liquide un
carburant extrêmement dangereux
bien que la nasa n'est donné que peu
d'informations dans l'après midi
il semble que l'on soit passé très près
d'une véritable catastrophe
côté humain il est facile d'imaginer les
angoisses de l'équipage cinq hommes et
une femme qui sur ces images débarque
pour la deuxième fois le premier départ
de discovery l'exemplaire numéro trois
de la navette est reportée de plusieurs
semaines
c'est la première fois depuis le premier
vol de la navette en avril 1980 que la
nasa doit faire face à de tels problèmes
avec son cargo de l'espace